breaking tonight the war on cops is far
from over a sheriff deputy was shot in
north carolina today during a traffic
stop is currently in stable condition
the suspect is in custody we're
monitoring this story and will bring you
any updates as they come in this as the
most liberal cities in america continue
to be standby destructive policies
manhattan d.a ivan bragg is at it again
as he allegedly reduced charges for a
brazen career crook
who robbed an innocent woman in new york
city now sources say that the mugger
told the arresting officer
quote next time i won't do it right in
front of you
the criminals are actually mocking us at
this point
here now with reaction to all of this
fraternal order of police national vice
president sergeant joe gomaldi
sergeant thanks so much for joining
cross country again
i want you to comment on the officer
that was shot earlier today but the fact
that the criminals are now making fun of
the entire criminal justice system
what's your reaction to that
well you know let me start with the
sergeant that was shot my thoughts and
prayers are certainly with him and you
know my heart breaks for him and his
family as they now have to deal with all
that but it's becoming an all too
familiar pattern we had 346 police
officers shot last year that was a
record since we started tracking this
already this year we've had 60 police
officers shot which is a 60 increase
over last year and you know i'm going to
put my uniform on immediately after this
and go out on patrol but you know before
i do i'm going to tell my officers make
sure you're careful out there because
criminals are thinking less and less of
shooting us and they're thinking less
and less of killing us because they know
they're not going to be held accountable
for their actions and yet we hear from
academics and so-called journalists
saying well your job's really not that
dangerous i'll tell you what once you
sit your ass next to me in that patrol
car and you see if you think my job is
dangerous and as far as d.a bragg is
concerned i mean is there someone who is
more out of touch with new yorkers than
d.a bragg and his staff a recent
quinnipiac poll said 74 percent of new
yorkers thought crime was a serious
problem and they're right and the brain
trust that the da's office thinks we
should go even softer on crime and to
talk about the criminal you mentioned
that guy's been arrested 46 times
46 and he was out on parole when he did
this grand larceny and the da's office
thinks it's a bright idea to actually
reduce the charge you do not cut a deal
with a repeat felon like this and what
it really tells the community and what
it tells victims is we don't give a damn
about you it certainly tells cops we
don't care about the risks you're taking
and to all your viewers if you have
people politicians in your community
that aren't embracing law and order you
need to get loud you need to talk about
it you need to hold them accountable and
vote them out because the consequences
are deadly you know i thought the whole
point of criminal justice reform was
when civil liberties were violated or
when criminals had reformed their their
lives
but that's not what's happening in these
progressive cities these people continue
they have rap sheets longer than cvs
receipts so it's very sad what's
happening in the country but i want you
to get the re i want to get your
reaction to this this is the wife of an
abra al quirky cop
that had some fired up rhetoric for
those leaders that aren't doing anything
about this watch
steadily gotten worse over the last two
years and it's because of the politics
it's the choices
[Music]
that they've made to throw our officers
away
what's your reaction sergeant
i'll tell you it's heartbreaking to hear
a talk about it but that's what we need
we need every american in this country
to stand up and fight against these woke
policies because we know they're an
unmitigated disaster i mean just in
albuquerque alone they were one of 16
american cities who experienced their
highest murder rate on record
on
record and yet they continue to move
forward with these policies and it's
killing our communities i mean it's not
hyperbole to say we're fighting for the
very soul of our country right now you
know what the worst part is you're not
doing the criminals a favor either
because maybe just maybe if we were hard
on them much like we were you were
talking about earlier on the homeless
situation if we took a hard line with
some of these folks maybe they would
actually straighten up maybe actually we
would get them on the right path but you
saw from the career criminal well
hopefully next time nobody will see me
do it and i'll get away with it and
that's the attitude and it needs to stop
sergeant until these folks hit rock
bottom they're not going to change their
lives that's someone that first job was
in a juvenile court i'm telling you i
know it to be true thanks so much for
your service sergeant hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else